really embarrassing that luke's not here
maybe i did embarrass myself from
unfortunate haircuts to hidden tears to
horses getting messy on set there were
countless embarrassing situations the
actors found themselves in while filming
we've got 10 scenes that the bridgerton
actors were most mortified filming
coming right up number one the cast
certainly wasn't expecting to see all
this on set i think that was probably
maybe the most disastrous thing that
happened
jonathan bailey bared his soul
and his crotch i think his his trousers
ripped at a certain point bayley was
filming one of his fabulous fencing
scenes suited up in what happened to be
very tight pants the trousers held up
through most of the shoot until bailey
made his final lunge in the match
in that particular moment there happened
to be four cameras on him and a set full
of cast and crew to capture this
embarrassing memory forever the actor
was so mortified literally all he could
do was scream this is so embarrassing
even though it's been a while since it
happened it's still haunts him so yes
it's true my coach my crotch did split
but that's testament to my athleticism
and the lunges number two regency era
romance on screen flawless in reality
well let's just say making out in a
corset isn't cute it may look good but
for functionality's sake simone ashley
was not a fan of it making out with
johnny in a corset there were a few
scenes where it was a bit couldn't lift
my arms up couldn't you know embrace as
much as i wanted to but we got there it
takes some planning for sure but to
achieve all that steamy romance so
beautifully
definitely worth it
number three he claims it was a
character choice but we know the truth
it's fine if i'm crying don't worry
about it filming the scene where
cherithra walks down the aisle was a
special experience for everyone since
they hadn't actually rehearsed it yet
wanting to capture as authentic a
feeling as possible but emotions got the
better of luke newton who was really
moved witnessing the moment even getting
a lump in his throat and trying to hold
back his tears that is until he
remembered who he was playing colin the
soppy romantic would surely be crying at
this moment so he did and then he got
caught and afterwards truthfully came up
to me and was like are you okay and i
was like yeah and she said johnny said
you were crying and i'm saying well
nearly yeah but i'm fine number four if
we know anything it's that herography
matters and there was a choice he was
making okay so during one of their
steamier encounters simone ashley got a
bit caught up in the moment and forgot a
key step and all the while her on-screen
love was trying to help her out but then
it just got awkward i forgot to take to
mime taking my hair down and johnny was
like looking up at me and he
was like
this didn't translate so well leaving
ashley confused and johnny embarrassed
at his actions
and then they all caught and he was like
number five animal co-stars really stole
the thunder in one particular scene the
most awkward moment on set happens when
i think yeah working with horses filming
a romantic moment can be awkward as is
but it's the worst when a horse co-star
intercepts stealing all the attention
and stinking up the joint you're doing a
beautiful scene
it's very romantic and it's going really
well and then a horse just takes a dump
yeah not such a romantic or cute scene
anymore how do you even continue filming
after that ashley was understanding of
the horse's needs at least you know when
nature calls
nature calls number six this was a
seriously competitive crew when the
bridgerton cast gets the chance to
compete on set they all bring their
a-game luke thompson gave it his all but
it happened to be a bit too much for his
mallet
even just trying to hit a ball i mean
that's how strong he is the actor broke
not one but two mallets filming the one
match but that didn't hold him back his
co-star claudia jesse explained that he
just kept going even though it was
clearly half a mallet all jagged wood
and the cameras are on he was just like
oh i've broken a second one but i'll
give it a go we can't say he wasn't
committed even if it left him
embarrassed on the field number seven
anyone know where colin bridgerton is
luke newton certainly didn't one of his
first days back on set unable to speak
in his character's voice for the life of
him it was a massive scene we were at
the races the pressure was on with loads
of moving parts and almost the entire
cast there it just wasn't coming out in
my column voice it was like the back of
my throat i was squeaking i sounded like
a disney character i was like what is
going on our pal luke happened to be
suffering a bit of stage fright it just
really overwhelmed me that like the
success of the show and suddenly i felt
like i was in bridgeton for the first
time considering how overwhelmed we get
just watching the show who can blame him
number eight but never without certain
rules in place the intimacy coordinator
of the second season of bridgerton
elizabeth talbot got very creative when
it came to sourcing props for the actors
to use as part of their three barrier
rule for when the action on screen got
hot and heavy there's a three barrier
rule which means you'll have your
barrier yeah i'll have mine and then
this would be the carbon flake
it made for some pretty awkward times
bailey explaining it's pretty silly
really and we have some hilarious
moments in addition to the half inflated
netball pillows and neck cushions were
go-to barriers on set if it works it
works
are the demands of the day affecting
your game brother number nine we'd be
lying if we said there wasn't some
cheating in the pal mao match daphne
stuns with her performance on set but
the reality well most of those shoots
took a fair amount of work and it wasn't
usually coming from dinner herself i was
probably the worst player pretty awkward
when you're supposed to be the best
player
the embarrassment was real as the
actress kept trying to make some shots
and help out so some of her gameplay
could actually be captured by the
cameras only to miss over and over and
over again
number 10 this shave was a bit too close
for comfort luke thompson is a jokester
and wanted to play some tricks on set
but wound up having a trick played on
himself so at one point jenny who was
our shared hair and makeup artist
pretended she shaved a lump out of the
back of his head and he he believed
now that is brutal but the fact that the
actor was actually really kind about it
and acted totally fine after the fact
despite feeling ashamed about his new
bald spot speaks volumes and just makes
us love him even more
as much as bridgeton is a total romance
the laughs we get from behind the scenes
and on screen always make it a fun watch
which situation do you think would have
been most embarrassing